vous avez votre livre famille monsieur
oui votre enfant est né le 13 octobre
1967 ni quels faits dont lui donner la
balle finit claire marie scène d'état
civil classique en somme qui se répète
ça sent fois par mois à la mairie
mais le père heureux ou sourire
satisfait at il pensé que la petite
delphine serait une jeune femme en l'an
2000 et qu'à l'époque rennes compterait
cinq cent mille habitants
rennes s'appelait jadis condat
c'est-à-dire confluent et au 10e siècle
déjà la position géographique conférant
à la ville une suprématie régionale
indiscutable en 15 144 le parlement de
bretagne s'y installe en 1720 un
terrible incendie détruit la cité
prospère mais le sinistre porte en lui
le germe de l'exemple sous l'impulsion
de louis 15
l'architecte gabriel et l'ingénieur
roblin tentent et réussissent elles à
des premières membres rendement de
l'histoire et réalise avant la date
les premières opérations de copropriété
il faudrait bien des heures pour conter
l'histoire de rennes s'attarder sur des
pages tour à tour sombre et glorieuse
pour en arriver à 39 45 au bombardement
à l'occupation à la libération au
renouveau et à l'extraordinaire
animation d'une grande idée moderne en
pleine expansion une rapide promenade
dans la périphérie de la ville est une
véritable découverte celle de
gigantesques silo de construction neuve
de building aux lignes futuristes de
traces et d'avenues rectiligne là où
quelques mois ou semaines auparavant
l'oeil ne s'attardait que sur le paysage
de la campagne d'ille et vilaine une
poussée subite soudaine venue de sang
côté à la fois avec même pourquoi ne pas
le dire le sentiment d'une certaine
incohérence au regard du visiteur non
averti
j'vais pas du tout incohérent c'est le
résultat d'un plan qui ait mis plusieurs
années à être élaboré et dont on ne voit
pas encore toutes les conséquences
mais il faut bien penser que la
construction d'une route ou la
construction des réseaux qui sont
indispensables pour l'expansion d'une
ville sont des travaux qui ne peuvent se
réaliser qu'avec beaucoup de temps il
est des investissements importants
c'est la raison pour laquelle la ville a
commencé par étudier le problème du
ravitaillement en eau de la population
est réalisée pour ce faire 35 millions
d'équipements et que nous avons investi
environ 20 millions pour établir un
réseau d'assainissement et cette usine
d'épuration qui est une des plus
importantes de france capitale en effet
était le problème de l'eau et la pose de
233 km de tuyauterie le capital celui de
l'assainissement avec ses 140 km de
canalisations
capitale celui des 38 km de rues
nouvelles réaliser le capital le
problème des grandes voies de
communication des grands axes de
dégagements sans lesquels nul expansion
d'une grande ville n'est possible
capitale l'avion les transports aériens
et les aménagements qu'ils comportent
plus comme ceux des voies de chemin de
fer en un mot tout une infrastructure
indispensable
difficile à imaginer et que soupçonne à
peine l'homme de la rue maintenant on
tente de rattraper le retard
enfin en fait je pense que et ce retard
ce retard est rattrapé rapidement ou
est-il rattraper moi je crois qu'il
n'est pas attraper je pense que depuis
plusieurs années déjà il ya un certain
progrès assez nets d'ailleurs je trouve
en est victime vite il prend de
l'importance mais aussi dans le commerce
xi a placé pour le voir j'habite en
dehors de la ville par la route que je
prenais visuellement
dan et veut maintenant il ya des maisons
qui longe trouvait depuis 1958 une
grande grande différence en ce qui
concerne surtout la périphérie de rennes
où il a créé plusieurs plusieurs
quartiers
oui oui il ya énormément de construction
qui se font et ça marche bien je prends
dans l'ensemble au point de vue commerce
c'est formidable ce type mais en
proportion je crois vers saint brieuc
comme expansion comme baptisé redd ne se
disent pas tellement la ville de rennes
s'étant tellement que en un petit peu
submergé en tous les cas je me dire que
par rapport aux grandes villes de france
comme grenoble ne la jouent que la ville
de rennes s'étant aussi bien que les
autres villes 90 mille habitants 39 180
milles à l'heure actuelle une population
dont 35% environ a aujourd'hui moins de
30 ans
la tâche est lourde est rude les
problèmes étaient nombreux il leur
fallait des solutions les rennais les
ont trouvés en ont du moins trouvé un
certain nombre avec bien entendu
efficace participation des pouvoirs
publics sans lesquels rien n'était
possible
plus de 24000 logement s'était construit
près de 700 classes ont été ouvertes ou
sont en voie de l'être le nombre des
étudiants est passé de 7500 à près de
15000 les facultés été reconstruites ou
rajeuni universités changé de visage et
se voyait couronné du complexe
scientifique de rennes beaulieu
bon
parallèle indispensable la nécessité de
trouver un équilibre sur le plan du
travail d'autant plus difficiles à
établir que la situation géographique
situe la ville au centre d'une région
éminemment agricole pourtant sans
industrialisation pad expansion possible
choix difficiles facilité pourtant par
la présence de l'université et sa
prédisposition à la recherche etc ce qui
devait influencer l'action des
responsables vers certaines
implantations industrielles dites de
pointe
après citroën c'était faire chez elle
c'était en tas puis le centre
électronique d'armement de bruz les
zones industrielles de la route de
lorient et de saint grégoire et travaux
feront que les rennais s'apercevront
très rapidement que ce qu'il assemble
peut être encore aujourd'hui incohérent
et en résumé en résumé le résultat d'une
étude patiente et de travaux
considérables que nous réalisons
systématiquement en sachant avant de les
entreprendre ou nous voulons arriver car
notre but c'est d'organiser une
agglomération non pas l'agglomération
rennaise d'aujourd'hui mais celle de
demain il y avait il y aura encore bien
des problèmes à résoudre dans une
civilisation qui est celle du travail et
du bien-être qui s'en suit
mais qui sera demain celle des loisirs
les espaces verts sont nécessaires en
même temps que les stades où les centres
culturels
la tâche est immense et pour les rennais
qui ont voulu leur reine
il ne semble pas que le grand prix
d'expansion dhabi française cette
distinction envier qu'ils recevront
demain soit un point final
et le lieu même où nous sommes mais ses
nombreux enfants que vous voyez vous
marque que nous sommes seulement une
étape ce sont ses enfants qui sont notre
préoccupation
notre souci est notre espoir tous nos
écrans actuellement tendent à leur
assurer l'avenir à permettre la création
d'emplois et disons s'ils voulaient bien
que rennes leur haine que nous concevons
actuellement est pour nous un instrument
nous pensons que le moment est venu de
nous associer avec ce qui n'est pas
rennes tout en étant quelque peu
nous allons tendre la main aux autres
communes et nous souhaitons que nous
puissions aboutir à une agglomération
fonctionner les nouvelles à la mesure de
notre temps et ainsi nous travaillerons
l'avenir de nos enfants et à l'avenir de
la bretagne entière à rennes de l'an
2001 reine de l'an ii mais il un renne
moderne 1 rennes travailleurs et un rain
hymne à la fois